>> WE KNOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE 28-YEAR-OLD GRADUATE
STUDENT, BRIAN KOHBERGER,
ARRESTED TODAY ON FOUR COUNTS
OF FIRST-DEGREE MURDER.
AND WE ARE ALSO LEARNING MORE
ABOUT HOW LONG HE WAS IN THE
SIGHTS OF AUTHORITIES.
SOURCES TELL ME TONIGHT THEY
WERE TRACKING HIM, WHEN HE WAS
DRIVING.
AND HE DROVE FROM IDAHO TO US
PARENTS HOME IN PENNSYLVANIA,
ARRIVING THERE IN PENNSYLVANIA
AROUND CHRISTMAS.
BUT THERE IS STILL MUCH WE DO
NOT KNOW ABOUT HIS BACKGROUND,
HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH A FOUR
PEOPLE HE IS ACCUSED OF
MURDERING, IF THERE EVEN WAS A
RELATIONSHIP, AND THE EVENTS
THAT LED TO THEIR DEATHS.
CNN'S CAMILLA BERNAL HAS MORE
ON WHAT WE KNOW.
>> A CALL TO THE PUBLIC, OF
OFFERING THE NEED OF ANY
INFORMATION REGARDING BRIAN
KOHBERGER.
>> WE STILL ASK FOR PEOPLE TO
CONTINUE SENDING THINGS INTO
THE TIP LINE.
>> HIS DNA AND WHITE HYUNDAI
ELANTRA LINKING HIM TO THE
CASE.
ACCORDING TO TWO LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOURCES BRIEFED ON
THE INVESTIGATION.
BUT MORE EVIDENCE IS NEEDED FOR
A SUCCESSFUL PROSECUTION.
>> WE ARE STILL LOOKING FOR
MORE INFORMATION.
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO BUILD
THAT PICTURE, JUST LIKE WE
STAYED ALL ALONG.
WE'RE PUTTING ALL THE PIECES
TOGETHER AND THAT'LL HELP.
>> BRIAN KOHBERGER --
>> THE 28-YEAR-OLD GRADUATED IN
MAY FROM DESALES UNIVERSITY IN
PENNSYLVANIA, WITH A MASTERS IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
>> IT'S SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN
DELVING INTO THE INNERMOST
SANCTUM'S OF CRIMINAL THINKING
WHO IS NOW ACCUSED OF A
PARTICULARLY HORRIFIC CRIME.
>> IN REDDIT POSTS REMOVED
AFTER THE ARREST WAS MADE
PUBLIC, A STUDENT INVESTIGATOR
NAMED BRIAN KOHBERGER SOUGHT
PARTICIPATION IN A RESEARCH
PROJECT ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DESALES UNIVERSITY STUDY.
IT WAS TO UNDERSTAND HOW
EMOTIONS AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
TRAITS INFLUENCE
DECISION-MAKING WHEN COMMITTING
A CRIME.
THE POST SAID THE STUDY SOUGHT
TO UNDERSTAND THE STORY BEHIND
YOUR MOST RECENT CRIMINAL
OFFENSE, WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
YOUR THOUGHTS AND FEELINGS
THROUGHOUT YOUR EXPERIENCE.
MOST RECENTLY, IT WAS A
GRADUATE STUDENT AT WASHINGTON
STATE UNIVERSITY'S DEPARTMENT
OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
CRIMINOLOGY.
>> I AM NOT AT ALL SURPRISED,
ALTHOUGH REALLY DISHEARTENED,
TO FIND OUT THAT THIS SUSPECT
IS A PH.D. STUDENT IN
CRIMINOLOGY AT WASHINGTON STATE
UNIVERSITY.
FROM THE OUTSET, WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS WASN'T
ORGANIZED KILLER.
>> HE WAS STUDYING AND LIVING
IN PULLMAN, WASHINGTON, JUST A
FEW MILES FROM THE CRIME SCENE.
POLICE SEARCHED HIS UNIVERSE
UNIVERSITY RESIDENCE FRIDAY
MORNING.
>> THIS IS A SMART GUY WHO'S
OBSESSED WITH CRIME.
>> HE WAS ARRESTED EARLY FRIDAY
MORNING, GIVING LAW ENFORCEMENT
A CLEAR FOCUS FOR THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
>> THIS IS NOT AN ENDING, BUT
RATHER A NEW BEGINNING.
>> CAMILLA BERNAL JOINS US NOW.
CAMILLA, WASHINGTON STATE
UNIVERSITY ALSO RELEASED A
STATEMENT TONIGHT.
WHAT DID THEY SAY?
>> WELL, PAMELA, THE CHANCELLOR
OF THE UNIVERSITY, SAYING THEY
ARE SHAKEN THAT THE ENTIRE --
G THEY ARE
SHAKEN, THAT THE ENTIRE REGION
IS SHAKEN BY THIS CRIME
-- THAT SHE HOPES THIS WILL BE
THE BEGINNING OF A HEALING
PROCESS.
NOW, IN TERMS OF THE
INVESTIGATION, THE UNIVERSITY
CONFIRMING THAT THEY HELPED, IN
TERMS OF THE UNIVERSITY POLICE,
EXECUTE THE SEARCH WARRANT.
THERE WERE TWO OF THEM, ONE TO
HIS APARTMENT, THE OTHER TO HIS
OFFICE.
THEY WERE BOTH ON CAMPUS, WITH
A UNIVERSITY SAYING, THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO ASSIST LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN ANY WAY
POSSIBLE.
AND THEN, FINALLY, PAM,
CONFIRMING THAT JUST THIS MONTH,
THE SUSPECT FINISHED HIS FIRST
SEMESTER.
HE WAS A PH.D. STUDENT IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PROGRAM.
AND, AGAIN, HE FINISHED THAT
SEMESTER JUST THIS MONTH, PAM.
>> CAMILLA BERNAL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
SO INTERESTING.
I'M JOINED NOW BY A RETIRED FBI
SPECIAL AGENT AND PROFILER WHO
WAS, HAS WORKED ON MANY
HIGH-PROFILE INVESTIGATIONS,
INCLUDING THOSE INVOLVING
ELIZABETH SMART AND AND
ACTUALLY HOLLOWAY.
AS WE REPORTED THE SUSPECT IN
CUSTODY HAS A MASTERS DEGREE,
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE, YOU JUST
HEARD THERE FROM KAMILA, HE
FINISHED HIS SEMESTER.
HE WAS STUDYING FOR HIS PH.D..
I WONDER, IS IT UNUSUAL SOMEONE
ACCUSED OF A CRIME LIKE THIS TO
HAVE AN EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND
IN CRIMINALITY?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> WELL, IT'S AN INTERESTING
QUESTION, BUT IT'S NOT UNHEARD
OF.
SO, WE HAD TED BUNDY WHO HAD A
BIG BACKGROUND IN PSYCHOLOGY,
BACHELORS DEGREE IN PSYCHOLOGY.
WE HAD BEAT IKE, SERIAL MURDER,
HIS BACKGROUND, HIS ACADEMIC
BACKGROUND WAS ALSO IN
CRIMINOLOGY.
SO, THAT'S NOT UNUSUAL, THAT
THEY WILL GO TO COLLEGE AND
THEY MAY EVEN DO WELL AND STUDY
IN AN AREA THAT THEY FIND OF
INTEREST.
THE UNABOMBER WAS A PH.D. IN
MATHEMATICS.
SO, WE DON'T WANNA MAKE TOO
MUCH OF IT UNTIL WE LEARN MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS
INDIVIDUAL, AND HOW HE WAS
USING AS ACADEMIC TRAINING,
ACADEMIC KNOWLEDGE, AND WAS HE
USING THAT TO HELP PLAN THESE
CASES, THESE CRIMES.
SO, I THINK THERE'S A LOT THAT
WE HAVE TO KNOW BEFORE WE CAN
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHERE THIS
KNOWLEDGE, WHERE THIS ACADEMIC
EXPERTISE COMES INTO PLAY.
>> RIGHT, AND AGAIN, HE'S STILL
THE SUSPECT, INNOCENT, UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY IN THIS COUNTRY.
BUT CERTAINLY, POLICE BELIEVE
THIS IS THEIR GUY.
THIS IS WHO THEY HAVE BEEN
SEARCHING FOR.
THIS IS THEIR SUSPECT.
AND WE ALSO LEARNED THAT A
PERSON NAMED BRYAN KOHBERGER
HAD WANTED TO PARTICIPATE IN A
STUDY AT HIS UNIVERSITY TO,
QUOTE, UNDERSTAND HOW EMOTIONS
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL TRAITS
INFLUENCE DECISION-MAKING WHEN
COMMITTING A CRIME, UNQUOTE.
IF THAT IS THE SAME BRYAN
KOHBERGER, DOES THAT TELL YOU
ANYTHING?
>> IF IT'S THE SAME PERSON, IT
CERTAINLY WOULD BE VERY
INTERESTING, BECAUSE IT WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE SUSPECT WAS
REALLY DRAWN TO THAT KIND OF A
TOPIC, THAT KIND OF STUDY, WAS
INTERESTED IN REALLY TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW MURDERS ARE
COMMITTED, AND WHAT'S GOING ON
IN PEOPLE'S HEADS.
SO, THAT WOULD CERTAINLY GIVE
THE INVESTIGATORS, AND SOME OF
THEM MIGHT BE PROFILERS, MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT, PERHAPS, HOW
WELL THIS CRIME WAS.
AND WHAT ELSE WENT INTO THAT
PLANNING?
HOW LONG WAS THAT PLANNING?
WHEN INTERVIEWING SOMEONE, YOU
REALLY HAVE TO DO YOUR HOMEWORK
OF THE SUSPECT.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND MORE
ABOUT THEM, AND WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO TELL YOU.
SO, IF THERE IS THIS KIND OF
PLANNING THROUGH ACADEMICS AND
THROUGH RESEARCH, IF YOU KNOW
ABOUT IT AHEAD OF TIME, AND IF
THEY SIMPLY SAY, I JUST DON'T
KNOW, I JUST DON'T KNOW WHY I
DID IT.
I JUST CHOSE THAT HOUSE, I WENT
IN THERE AND I DID IT.
YOU WOULDN'T KNOW BASED ON YOUR
KNOWLEDGE AND YOUR OWN HOMEWORK
THAT IS SIMPLY NOT THE CASE.
>> AND THE OTHER CASES YOU
MENTIONED, IS IT TYPICAL THAT
THE PERSON IS ALREADY HAS THOSE
INTERESTS AND COMMITTED A CRIME,
HAD ALREADY BEEN HAVING
IMAGINING IT, AND THEN THEY GO
ON TO STUDY IT --
OR COULD IT BE THAT SOMEONE
GOES AND STUDIES IT, AND
SUDDENLY, THEY'RE JUST REALLY
INTERESTED IN IT, AND THEN,
THEY WANT TO PUT IT TO USE?
>> NO, IT'S REALLY THE FORMER.
IT'S AN INTEREST, IT'S THERE.
AND THEY PURSUE THAT ACADEMIC
INTEREST.
BUT THE PERSONALITY IS SUCH,
PERSONALITY IS REALLY INVOLVED,
SOMEONE THAT IS IN MANY CASES,
VERY COLD BLOODED, VERY
PREDATORY IN THEIR ACTIONS,
WITHOUT EMPATHY FOR ANOTHER
HUMAN BEING.
SO, THE ACADEMICS DON'T
DETERMINE TH